Changez you punch me I'm so overwhelmed
[Music]
we're here we're doing it today we're
raising kids so I'm gonna be raising
someone else's child for a day oh good
luck I don't know what to think you're
not qualified so what was I like as a
toddler complete pain in the ass yeah
babe didn't every been one year two and
year three you're really strong will be
my wife are pretty close to having
children I'm still not so good at taking
care of myself
I'm not the most fond of babies gonna be
fun I'm a boy I got along with boys I'm
gonna look at all these toys we're gonna
have a great time it's tiring you're
losing sleep every day is new it's like
I had a tornado for a pet there he goes
I have to go it's like taking care of
your drunk front my name is David I have
a 14 month old son Isidore your rocks
now anything that he is not supposed to
get he wants what did you just find on
this yeah not good dude Dominic is 22
months just turned it Oh as soon as it's
in his mouth the time it's just really
going at it just really chewing it this
is a two-year-old
good cat better dad than me so this is
Oscar and then I have a seven week old
at home he did say at one point he
wanted to throw in the trash game don't
take a book from a babysitter what I
consider the obvious reasons
but this is your life this is Odysseus
he is one Ajax is for and Rex is six
second 1/2
what's it like to be a dad cause to care
when you have a kid you sign up for
stress as soon as this get to like ten
months that's when they start crawling
and that's crazy town he's like a wild
little beast you don't get anything done
I mean you go to sleep at 1:32 you got
it for 5:30 you see me you know me how
do I get I don't know so I'm gonna I
guess sort of reverse Asian this and be
the adoptive father hello Oscar I'm Ned
so I'm your I'm your dad now I'll be
hanging out with you today does that
sound like a good time you know you're
not gonna like throw up on me are you
come here dum dum clacking the baby was
never in any of my parenting books this
trip six times it'll have to yeah boring
[Music]
there you go dude children often try to
just get away that one does yeah all
right well it looks like you have your
work cut out for you then is it mean for
me to say I want out
do you think I'm gonna do well oh it's
daddy time my main goal today is just to
make sure that the kid doesn't die
make sure nobody chokes to death I've
never choked to death so I'm an expert
my strengths today are I got a lot of
energy I'm ready to go and my weaknesses
are I don't know anything this is your
domain you can be daddy now I am daddy
you basically just keep him alive
he needs to change this is what he wore
to sleep hopefully I don't this up he
does repeat things so watch out okay
good luck thank you you were dad to me I
will be in the other room boys entertain
him I will um figure out what to do with
you dumb oopsie
already hates me already doesn't want to
stay with me I'm to a great start I
should take care of this kid right
I was the youngest of three boys but
I've never dealt with the the chaos that
was my own childhood dynamic all right
I'm your dad today
could we could we put down the screen
hey Jax he still isn't of the age where
you can reason with him Tom where'd you
go hey ajax ajax tom your dad's
i'm your dad now and screen times over i
don't know where you're going hey let's
do you take your own shirt off or do you
want me help you or what but Tom wait
for me dum-dum-dum
hey Jack where are you hey Jack's we
don't need the cupcake ten what here why
are you opening this okay and now we got
Star Wars Oh tell him Dan run around
naked it this not me no no not to me
oh you okay over there Ajax follow me
oh wait no that's what you do a dog all
right baby give me that baby the baby's
awake it's time to add another child to
this because I've been too much control
I need to go take care of your brother
and then what can you guys you guys want
to give them a screen for a minute what
do you do you got five minutes of screen
time how's that sound
try not to kill each other while I'm
gone yeah don't
Wow I feel like that's a pretty obvious
reason hey who's this it's a stranger
good morning Otis what are you wearing
you are too adorable is killing it those
blue squares when you have kids your
home life changes dramatically
especially the first one notice you do
not smell the best so I've got my day
job so a lot of days I'm just not home
we do one so those nights where I am
home were nice where she works then the
sort of understanding is I will try to
do everything then hi boys how you doing
I got a third boy for you oh no what do
you mean oh no he's trouble I mean I
have all these advantages and it's hard
as hell I've got a wife who's a great
partner I've got a good job my kids are
healthy and it's super super super all
right look at her in band hey guys look
at him dance given that how dare I not
at least do my best at this
Hey hey guys hey hey hey hey both of you
okay guys guys hey hey Rex
you guys both apologize to each other
for hitting each other you can not
everything's a teachable moment that's
the other thing and that's taken me
three kids and the six years to figure
out create or we chill
hey what don't get it give me that
screen doors how do I get him to like me
the way you would want to get anyone to
like you I'm still trying to figure that
out dumb you want to play with Chuck
okay I think he understood I said he's
happy unless he cries right I mean he
can get stoked wrap yeah throw things
we're gonna make something to eat I
don't even know where to start
yeah yeah I really regret taking you out
of the seat you're doing a great job
unpacking oh yeah I'm sorry you didn't
hear that I know
oh man see if he retained the second
part of that sentence hey you'll go fast
then go weak
a little bit of a whiplash there you get
normally I think why babies are not that
cute but this one's really cute
congratulations
I think he's I think he's getting the
hang of it
now the ultimate challenge of the dad
using an oven while holding a baby again
[Music]
oh no don't actually do it though no no
no no no they have a tendency to put
everything in his mouth no no no no no
no kids a lot to eat Chuck
probably not okay just take that off oh
yeah look they can't just eat flour you
were know he's eating a pencil so we're
almost halfway through this day and
Oscar and I still aren't really
connecting you want to walk around the
kitchen with me that did it did it did
it did
there's no whoa as I like as a child you
were you weren't verbal at all in the
beginning
cook know how to play the guitar how do
you know when you're ready to have kids
you're never ready got use your feet all
right
that's the relationship like no other I
think my wife and I are pretty good at
communicating but it's next level day so
I oh yeah bounce house bounce house my
relationship with my wife is 50/50 in
terms of like the responsibilities we
share because I feel like if this is
really fun about noticing that it's very
hot outside and all right here we go
yeah how do you get him to be still or
quiet sir calm I called Rex out on this
cheating and then we started robbing the
bank
all right buddy party let's do it okay
it isn't it's a lot about like just kind
of keeping things moving you're gonna
break it you don't know let's less maybe
not do money party again we just got rid
of all right guys it is time for lunch
so screen time is done ready for
Nandanam yeah I know he does love food
um give me one second if we gave this to
him he would he's eaten the whole rind
yes this is fun I like watching him
hunger out where his mouth is I think
what's really interesting about this
stage is the notion of no hey guys guys
he done that's a smart kid he's gonna
kind of like start presenting you all
these alternatives want to bag on thank
ya the reason why it's terrible twos is
because they're gonna challenge your
authority and see how far they can push
it where's that good no no that's it
that's it that's it for today no more
numbness Oscar I'm still in the bounce
house and sometimes he'll just give it
right back to me you say no as a dad now
you have to let them know that you're in
charge you can't let them run over you
Oscar that's enough for either bouncing
or in a not bouncing then what have you
read revelation hey Jack
alright that's it young man there's no
more bounce house today thanks buddy
God hey hey no
okay
[Music]
it's just a house now there's no anymore
okay I'm sorry I didn't mean to raise my
voice it's okay it's alright we just you
got to put your shoes back on okay Oscar
is the more you do it then you
understand how to like navigate these
turn off the light yeah guys really glad
they're on that ketchup
I think most kids do
give myself a D we like a book yeah well
I'd love to hear it I'm actually kind of
glad that's the end I think probably the
importance of nap time is more for the
parents and for the child your kid uses
diapers still yes and one he's 14 months
well I don't know you just want to get
determined what do you think is there
something there have like any like
really gnarly poops to this day you
still do that's a big one it's a big one
it got up to your leg how did that
happen you had an office job before you
had him no I'm gonna worked at BuzzFeed
can't be wimpy about this yeah I mean
you know it's a demanding job no and you
don't wipe up because you don't want to
put it in it in his yes okay I mean my
grandfather changed one diaper for kids
his entire life in his entire life
you're being real delicate well he's a
delicate babe and I don't want to be
that person oh I took this I wanted to
figure out a way to put Isadora in the
center of my
I think he's saying I love him so much
that he sort of put me in a totally
different mindset than I even thought I
was capable of
I need to wash my hands okay let's go
the best thing that I can offer him is
myself nothing beats the real thing
Oh boys y'all want to go outside oh yeah
oh yeah the thing is you actually you
put the kid in there first and then you
strap on all that other stuff biscuits
[Music]
yo it's not the popsicles
[Music]
[Applause]
when you're making this look like having
a baby everyone just loves you just let
it go feels good feels good how'd you
get a camera back
get out your mouth that's disgusting he
has discovered stares
we were just constantly finding danger
are you also you know I don't really
like babies very much give any advice
for how to try to connect with a little
kid act American you up three-year-old
what a nice day it was monkey so I'm
gonna become a monkey what does the
zebra say yeah we're trying to learn
exactly a couple of crazy things happen
that let's surrogacy happen in my life
no that's
I actually co-parent him with a friend
of mine who's his bio mom gotcha he's
married to another woman Oh gay dude dad
lesbian mom that explains all the denim
I didn't say that you did and this is a
really bumpy sidewalk
this is off-roading basically jeez all
right I knew that there would be a huge
hole in my life if I hadn't gone through
this experience I've only been with them
for several hours and I'm already
exhausted we
OOP welcome to daddy's world all those
stereotypes about a love that you never
saw before is totally there what oh my
gosh
okay okay you're really milking this
right now baby
how do you feel like I don't know more
comfortable doing this now I understand
him more but the idea that like your job
is never done
I think that's something I will never
fully appreciate until I mean it yeah
because how could you I always thought
about having kids but I think I'm less
I'm realizing that I'm less tired fied
of kids and maybe more terrified of
being a bad dad I'm always thinking like
maybe if I had a kid I would kind of
make it a little fu cked up you know
like it would be maybe too much like me
in some ways you will probably feel
uniquely unqualified to do this and you
are but so am i and I actually do this
you're never gonna be the person that
you're supposed to be until the end of
it but and then partly he will help
shape the person who you become so just
try your best huh that's basically it
what I learned today it's pretty much
chaos all the time
Ajax is all the way over there I'm just
spinning a barrel I am so tired
that's like without Kidd tired that is
not the same I need to take a nap now I
don't know how my parents did it there
are certainly single dads out there and
I don't know how they do it it's a lot
you got to be active in this thing too
if you're gonna go through the process
of making a kid you got to show up I'll
cheer here's the dares your dad's
everywhere I'm drinking wine out of a
sippy cup but it's worth it oh yeah oh
yeah this is pretty fun I love to climb
also it smells like ketchup
Sunday I'll have kids okay I get that
don't laugh if I wasn't a good day oh
you didn't put the top on you did great
anytime the camera wasn't rolling also
something like this was happening so
just rest assure but I've never been
yeah but when a piece of advice in order
to have kids that I've found is it helps
to have sex well yeah okay that's that's
a a rude way to end this day